the next call of duty title may be
arriving sooner than expected gta online
adds a new multiplayer mode and more
the next game in the call of duty
franchise for 2022 might be coming
sooner than we think due to the low
sales of vanguard according to tom
henderson who has leaked accurate
information in the past for previous
call of duty titles battlefield 2042 and
more he said in a tweet as expected it's
looking like this year's call of duty
title modern warfare 2 2022 will be
revealed in the summer hearing rumblings
that the title could release in october
due to vanguard's poor sales performance
with a quote-unquote big warzone update
coming soon after this comes right after
activision released a statement in which
it acknowledged the frustrations some
players are reporting across the suite
of call of duty games promising that
fixes and improvements are coming the
company said player feedback is critical
to the development process and told fans
to keep an eye out for upcoming changes
rockstar games has announced a new
multiplayer mode for gta online called
double down in double down you play as
franklin or lamar in a co-op experience
where you face a brutal onslaught of
enemies franklin and lamar as a team of
two face off against other human players
in this head-to-head mode the twist is
that the attackers only have a double
barrel shotgun while franklin and lamar
have access to more powerful weapons
both sides earn three times gta money
and rp just for trying double down and
as an added incentive rockstar is paying
everyone a lump sum of 200k gta dollars
just for playing one round double down
comes to gta online as part of the
game's latest update which also adds the
new nagasaki shinobi motorcycle which
rockstar said in the description that
it's agile powerful and angrier than a
bulldog chewing on a wasp this machine
is a work of art asking to be
simultaneously caressed and pushed to
its limits alright rockstar but what do
you think of this new bike let me know
in the comments
ubisoft has announced a partnership with
path to create a location-based vr
escape game inspired by the upcoming
movie notre dame on fire from director
jean-jacques annad the game is described
by variety as a one-hour experience
players will take on the role of a
member of the parisian fire brigade on
april 15 2019 the night the iconic
cathedral went up in flames ubisoft
executive deborah papernick said in a
statement that like any escape game it's
a question of puzzles and cooperating
with your teammates the idea is to make
your way through the cathedral to find
relics and to fight the fire because you
have to save notre dame before the clock
runs out notre dame on fire which is the
name of the film and the game are set to
release in march ubisoft which is based
in paris committed more than five
hundred thousand dollars to
reconstruction efforts and made
assassin's creed unity free for a
limited time in honor of the cathedral
first it was the matrix now it's notre
dame what are some other movies that are
coming out that you would like to see a
video game experience for let me know in
the comments and be sure to leave a like
subscribe and have a wonderful weekend
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you